hi I'm Erik Bosse and this is a
breakdown of the Dark Knight Rises
directed by Christopher Nolan and
written by Nolan and Jonah Nolan with
story by David s Goyer after nerding out
hard over Batman Begins in the Dark
Knight we now arrive at arguably the
most ambitious film of Nolan's trilogy
so let's rewatch The Dark Knight Rises
scene by scene to discover all the
subtle details and the influences and
the connections to the other films and
I'm gonna pack all the interesting stuff
in a fraction of the movies nearly three
hour runtime so if you'd like The Dark
Knight Rises then you're gonna love me
yeah
voices lurch good started the Dark
Knight Rises open similarly to the first
two movies of the trilogy with the
Batman logo emerging from some elemental
imagery that poor shadows the hero's
coming struggle Batman Begins derived
the Batman logo from the swarm of bats
for Bruce's struggle to construct his
identity from that which he fears the
Dark Knight showed the Batman logo
engulfed in flames for Batman's
trial-by-fire by the Joker and now the
Batman logo is formed by cracking ice
the ice foreshadows the literal ice that
the condemned Gothamites are exiled out
upon but also the breaking of Batman's
body and soul by Bane each of these
three movies can be boiled down to one
thematic word Batman Begins was about
fear the dark night was about chaos and
this movie is all about pain opening
with the Batman logo being created by
breaking ice conveys the theme of this
film that pain and suffering are
necessary for a hero to rise a thematic
counterpoint to the Joker's opening
declaration that whatever doesn't kill
you makes you not stranger but strong
jerk over the cement we hear the voice
of Commissioner Gordon delivering the
end of Harvey Dent's eulogy which we saw
at the end of the Dark Knight this
reminds us of that noble lie that Gordon
told about Gotham's White Knight the
hero Gotham needed right then to inspire
them into public service and to look
down upon the world of shadows but it
warns us that this movie will deal with
the consequences of that noble lie how
that sunny inspiration resulted in a
blind spot seething and resentment and
Gotham's underworld waiting to be
provoked and weaponized and right after
this Nolan introduces the threat that
will exploit that blind spot Bane he
hijacks and crashes his plane the CIA
agent here bill Wilson is played by
Aidan Gillen aka Littlefinger from Game
of Thrones pretty much all the smaller
parts in this movie are somebody you'll
recognize you
but he wanted to be in this movie
Littlefinger uses a little game making
the mercenaries think he's killing their
friends but really just trying to get
info on Bane but of course he's really
just a part of a larger game that he
doesn't know about this parallels a
moment in the Dark Knight remember
Harvey Dent tried to play a game by
flipping a coin to force a confession
but he didn't realize that he was just
playing right into the Joker's game to
corrupt him meanwhile Bane's moves are
echoing the Joker intentionally getting
himself caught to position himself to
enact an even more heinous plan Bane is
played by Tom Hardy whom Nolan had just
worked with in the movie Inception as
opposed to that one-dimensional
monstrous version of Bane from Batman
and Robin Nolan and Hardy went back to
the source material in the DC Comics
Bane is more of an intellectual figure
the one Batman villain no to really
break the bat both physically and
psychologically which is something he
does in the famous nightfall comic which
was a major influence on this movie Bane
spent his childhood in a prison in the
fictional Caribbean country of Santa
Prisca
working out and educating himself in the
comic version of the guy wears an
apparatus that pumps him with a steroid
that gives him temporary super strength
in the movie Hardy's strength is natural
he gained 30 pounds for the role and if
you look closely you can see pained
snappy in the zip tie behind his back
bro just whoops and of course there's
Hardy's voice joshing this would
something he was given quite a bit of
grief over but this wasn't a random
choice Hardy actually based the voice on
Bartley Gorman well I got man in front
of me they tried to kill me twice a
white me off the face of the earth he
was a UK bare-knuckle boxing champion
physical fierce presence and a major
badass but he just had a very particular
voice Hardy invoked this voice along
with the intellectual backstory of Bane
to give him this very particular way of
talking no survivors
by the way Gorman was also a Romani so
Hardy was inspired by that ethnic
backstory as opposed to the traditional
Latino backstory of Bane we learn later
that Bane's mask here gives him an
anesthetic for the pain for the
mutilations he received in prison so
kind of like the Joker these battle
scars make him a more fearsome presence
like you just don't screw around with
men who clearly live in constant pain it
almost suggests the idea that if you
were to hit them they wouldn't feel the
pain that you try to induce on them
Nolan has said that each of his Batman
movies are defined by their villains
more than the hero and it's interesting
that Bane along with Ra's al Ghul in the
Joker begins this
movie hiding in plain sight as well
patiently listening the others spreading
the rumors about him and waiting for the
right moment to reveal himself nolan
also put a lot of thought into making
the villains true ideological opposites
to the hero no one cared who I was till
I put on the Mars booth Bane and Batman
are ex members of the League of Shadows
and they both wear masks they're really
two sides of the same coin
Batman has shared a similar duality with
all of the villains of these movies each
hour opposite ends on a different axis
now Batman and Bane along with Talia al
Ghul we later learned exists on the axis
of Cruelty remember Bruce left the
League of Shadows because it was too
cruel whereas Bane was excommunicated
because he was too cruel Bane and Talia
share razza cynicism but they escalate
his fear tactics to be even more
sadistic the same gives us a powerful
example of Bane's extreme nature big guy
for you yeah well sure that but also
they expect one of us to the wreckage
brother have you stepped in the fire yes
the fire rises so a few things here one
this shows us that Bane's men are so
zealous that they're willing to give up
their lives just for this cause the fire
rises is also a direct quote from
Charles Dickens novel A Tale of Two
Cities which was a major literary
inspiration for the movie attila two
cities focuses on economic inequality
and social upheaval during the French
Revolution I'll actually point out more
a tale of two cities references as we go
then we hear the musical theme that Hans
Zimmer composed for being
Zimmer mixed in his traditional heavy
percussion with this Moroccan chant it's
the same chant that Bruce later hears in
the prison it's the phrase deshi Basara
which translates to rise up the overhead
shot of the plane dropping away from
Bane and pavo it's just amazing no one
said this whole sequence was actually
his favorite part to shoot of the entire
trilogy there's a ton of practical
components and stunts and special
effects that went into pulling this
whole thing off you can almost see Nolan
kind of priests storyboarding his shots
and Dunkirk while he was directing this
also all of this was shot in the IMAX
aspect-ratio
Nolan experimented with using IMAX 70
millimeter film in the dark night for
some of the scenes but now and Rises he
shoots as much as possible in IMAX
sometimes cutting back to normal 35
millimeter within the same scene just
because IMAX cameras are really too loud
to record audio with we move on to
Gotham City which you'll notice looks
different from the previous two films
Nolan based Gotham in the first two
movies on the city of Chicago but here
Nolan escalates to look at the city by
including shots of New York Los Angeles
and Pittsburgh everything and the Dark
Knight Rises is on a much larger scale
than it was in the previous film we see
mayor garcia honoring the eight year
anniversary of Harvey Dent's death and
the passage of the dead act which
resulted in over a thousand convictions
and past breakdowns I talked about how
Nolan's trilogy very much reflects post
9/11 America with the debate over
Batman's surveillance system echoing the
debate over the NSA's surveillance
through the Patriot Act the dent act
reflects the impact of the Patriot Act
when it came to policing power in
increased incarceration we meet Gordon's
second-in-command and upcoming
replacement Peter Foley played by
Matthew Modine he speaks with
congressman Gilly meanwhile John Daggett
tries to talk to Bruce along with
Miranda Tate now Daggett is a corporate
rival played by Ben Mendelsohn who often
plays villains his name could be a nod
to Roland Daggett a corporate villain in
Batman the Animated Series who's
actually responsible for creating
Clayface Miranda Tate we later learn is
actually the villain Talia al Ghul
daughter to Ra's al Ghul she's played by
Marion Cotillard who was cast after
playing the villain Maul from inception
in the comics Talia is heir to her
father's organization and a recurring
love interest kind of for Batman the way
she is in this movie she later leads the
League of Assassins
associated with League of Shadows notice
what Daggett says here everyone knows
that Wayne's holed up in there with
8-inch nails peeing into mason jars
Daggett is actually alluding to Howard
Hughes who was an eccentric billionaire
who became an infamous recluse in his
later years which is a fairly apt
description for Bruce Wayne at the
beginning of this movie it's interesting
how one of Hughes's last great public
beats was piloting the Spruce Goose it
was an all wooden airplane that he flew
out over the ocean
interesting Lee Bruce follows a similar
arc in this movie he finally returns
from his seclusion and he ends by
showing off his aviation skills we also
meet Selina Kyle Anne Hathaway she's
disguised as a maid and she breaks into
Bruce's private quarters to rob him
Selina Kyle is of course Catwoman though
this movie never explicitly labels her
as such the closest we get are a few
newspaper headlines that refer to her as
the cat for her cat's burglar arene the
pearl necklace that she steals belonged
to Bruce's mother Martha remember we saw
that necklace break in the flashback in
Batman Begins suggesting that Bruce has
now reassembled it the fact that Bruce
is so reluctant to part ways with this
necklace shows that he still hasn't
truly gotten over the deaths of his
parents or the death of Rachel Dawes
whose photos sits beside the photo of
his parents on his grieving desk
Bruce is clearly broken at the beginning
of this film his body is broken he needs
a cane after all of his internal
injuries over the years and his heart is
broken over the people he's lost we'll
see how the events of this movie
transitioned him from being a broken
person to a whole person and of course
this older cane sporting version of the
character Bruce Wayne it's taken from
Frank Miller's The Dark Knight Returns
comic which I mentioned is a major
influence for all three of these movies
also notice Selena's exit but name is
Joey this could be a nod to Letty Lamarr
that was the real-life original
inspiration for the Catwoman character
she was someone Hathaway studied
intensively in preparation for the role
Lamarr famously told a tall tale
claiming to have escaped from her
possessive arms-dealer husband by
dressing up as a maid and collecting all
of her jewelry and jumping out a window
Gordon meets with John Blake he's a cop
played by Joseph gordon-levitt another
one of Nolan's inception cast members to
make it into this movie and this movie
features Alfred retracing his footsteps
from The Dark Knight serving food to
master Bruce just to find him not there
so instead he descends down into Bruce's
man cave and like in Batman Begins the
Batcave is accessed through a three note
sequence on the piano now the notes have
been changed to the highest octave D and
E then down to a and B then back to the
Black Keys D flat and E flat it's a
little more complicated of a scheme than
the three notes and Batman Begins
remember it's always smart to change
your locks especially after a cold
burned down your house in the Batcave
the name that links to Salinas
thumbprint is an interesting Easter Egg
Nicolai on dredge Co nicolai under eco
whatever was it was the same alias that
the Joker used to author the mayor's
obituary in The Dark Knight somewhere in
the nolan vs. guys in jail thinkin why
does anyone use my name for crack on
dredge Co is actually the name of a
construction worker who worked on a
second two movies and fun fact the last
five letters of the name are an anagram
for the Joker Alfred urges Bruce to move
on with his life and when Rachel comes
up notice that Zimmer brings back that
same sad music I did find Jean I know
and you lost him but that's all part of
Lily's show but you're not living your
just waiting hoping for things to go bad
again
this is the same Rachel theme that
Zimmer used after her death in the Dark
Knight but is breakfast
alfrid once again brings up this whole
pain theme he confessed that he never
wanted Bruce to return to Gotham because
it brings in too much pain
instead he shares a fantasy of seeing
Bruce at peace at a cafe in Florence but
of course that's just a dream Bruce
hasn't yet suffered enough to earn this
kind of retirement but for us as an
audience alfred is giving us this image
as kind of a light at the end of the
tunnel to look forward to at the end of
the movie blake follows a lead to an
orphan kid who draws this chalk icon of
the batman logo now remember Gordon was
forced to smash the main bat signal at
the end of the dark night so this little
doodle was this kid's own little baby
bat signal
it's a desperate call for Batman to come
in return and help fix his shattered
world this image comes back later
meanwhile Selina hands off Bruce Wayne's
fingerprints to Phillips driver now
Stryver works for Daggett and he shares
his name with a character in Dickens A
Tale of Two Cities we also meet Selena's
friend Jen who's played by Juno temple
the character appears to be based on
Holly from the Batman year one comic
Selena and Holly had worked together as
sex workers and it was implied that they
shared a romantic relationship after
Gordon's close call with Bane Blake
meets with Bruce saying his superiors
don't believe his conspiracy theory
about an underground army in the sewers
they asked me if he saw any giant
alligators this seems like a nod to the
character Killer Croc the Batman villain
who resides in Gotham sewers could also
just be a joke about the urban myth that
alligators and bested all of New York
sewers which kind of influenced the
existence of the character Killer Croc
here Blake reveals that he had figured
out that Bruce was Batman a long time
ago and he did it just through empathy
that as a kid who had to grow up without
parents as well he could see that inner
pain underneath Bruce's false public
persona and of course we learned later
that Blake's legal name is Robin and
levites version of the character is kind
of a mix of the various versions of
Robin from over the years
the original Dick Grayson who became
Nightwing and Jason Todd who similarly
grew up as a tough street kid Tim Drake
was the third kid to take on the Robin
identity and in the comics Drake deduced
at a young age who Batman and Robin
really were just like this movie version
oblique does when he was a kid
Bruce checks into a hospital and the
doctor hears a cameo by comedian Thomas
Lennon from Reno nine one one four Nolan
in memento but the reason Bruce is going
here is to check in with Gordon
babbles about his guilt over that noble
lie and his fear that it didn't really
cure Gotham's ills
Gordon fears that the Joker was right
that Harvey Dent's fall from grace was
really a loss in the battle for Gotham
soul and if Gordon's right on those
fears Gotham would now return to this
state it wasn't Batman Begins if it
never really truly stepped forward now
it would be crumbling in the grip of the
League of Shadows interestingly the
League of Shadows in this movie uses the
same means to spread its evil the city's
own infrastructure and Batman Begins
they use the water pipes that flow
throughout the city and in Rises they
use the water lines that flow out of the
city Bruce then attends Miranda Tate's
charity ball which gives us our first
clue about Miranda's hidden agenda
notice how she greets Bruce masked like
the way pretty much all the villains
hide their identities Miranda also says
this line you have to be invested to
restore balance to the world
that's a pretty cryptic way to describe
charity work of course this restore the
balance talk is Miranda slash Talia
echoing the talking points of her father
every time a civilization reaches the
pinnacle of its decadence we return to
restore the balance also the music being
played during the gala is Maurice Ravel
piece titled Pavan for dead princess
which could be foreshadowing the way
this dark Eris's journey ends Bruce
dances with Selina who embraces her
cat-burglar record with her cat ears and
she warns Bruce about the volatile class
divided between the two of them storm
coming mr. Wayne
you and your friends better batten down
the hatches cuz when it hits you're all
gonna wonder how you ever thought you
could never so large and leave so little
Selena is kind of using some Marxist
language here and it's establishing
these two characters as opposing forces
on another axis an axis of income
inequality again the first two Nolan
Batman movies evoke the post 9/11
America but Rises adds to that political
backdrop the economic tensions of more
recent years with the Occupy Wall Street
movement after the 2008 bank bailouts
Selena's image of a storm also comes
from A Tale of Two Cities the third
chapter of which is titled track of a
storm and the Dark Knight Rises is a
tale of two Gotham's the Gotham of the
wealthy elite basking in pride over
burying the trash and the Gotham of the
oppressed masses ready to boil over and
overturn that social order much like the
revolutionaries in Dickens novel
Bruce meets with Lucius Fox and while he
waits in his office check out the book
he's reading it's kind of hard to tell
but it kind of looks like the cover
might have an image of Heath Ledger's
Joker on it it's hard to say either way
but if it is him this would be the only
reference to the Joker in this movie the
filmmakers said that they wanted to keep
e Ledger's presents limited to the
previous movie as a way to honor his
memory so even though it looks a lot
like him I'm guessing probably not him
Fox also gives Bruce a tour of his
armory with several new tumblers in the
batwing nicknamed in this movie the bet
and it makes a call back to the line
from Batman Begins does it come in black
and yes mr. Wayne it does come in black
there was actually a deleted part of the
scene that showed Fox giving Bruce his
exoskeletal brace that he puts on his
leg which we later see him do in the
Batcave it allows Bruce to walk straight
and kick through a brick wall this could
have been inspired by the Justice League
graphic novel Kingdom Come which takes
place in a hypothetical future in which
an older version of Bruce Wayne has this
kind of tech to help him move
Alfred also debriefs Bruce on Bane's
origin there is a prison in
ancient part of the world a pit where
men are thrown to suffer and die but
sometimes a man Rises notice how the
editing syncs up Alfred saying the word
rise with an image of Batman suit rising
from the ground Albert is talking about
Bane's rise from the pit which of course
is just a legend it was really Talia who
rose from the pit but either way this
shot for shadows Bruce's parallel rise
from the pit as he completes his journey
from death to resurrection later in the
movie and one fun little detail before I
move on if you look closely you can see
a scar on Bruce's arm this is the scar
from the Rottweiler attack in the Dark
Knight that nasty one that we saw him
and Alfred stitching up moving on to the
Gotham stock exchange again the conflict
here is rooted in economic inequality
Bane and his men pose as blue-collar
workers or custodian shoe-shiner a food
delivery man and they attack upper-class
investment bankers who look down on them
they're literally occupying Wall Street
in this scene you can also see some
close-ups of Bane's head which has an
interesting scar there's actually some
significance to this scar that I will
come back to later Bane and his men hack
into banking software and they take off
on motorcycles leading to a police chase
and Batman's first appearance in the
movie which really excites this older
cop this exchange between veteran and
rookie cop is lifted directly from
Miller's The Dark Knight Returns while
this all goes down we see Selina cat
burgler in again and I love the costume
design of her goggles which she lifts up
over her head to kind of look like cat
ears this is yet another example of
Nolan justifying character design from
the comics with practical functionality
and another detail I liked about this
sequence notice the close-up of the
tablet it shows that it will take
another 90 seconds for the application
to go through Nolan edits the rest of
the sequence to transpire in real time
so that exactly 90 seconds in our time
later the countdown expires and we see
Batman looking at the tablet right as
the application completes Nolan in
general is extremely particular about
the passage of time in his movies and
while he doesn't play around with it in
these movies as much as he does and
inception or memento he still has his
eye on the clock just as we saw in that
similar specificity with the timers in
the Hong Kong sequence of The Dark
Knight
he does it again later in this movie I
pointed out when we get there you may
have noticed that the background of this
chase looks a little different from the
ones
in the dark night that was all shot in
Chicago this is in downtown Los Angeles
Nolan shot this part here because the
freeways of downtown LA are known for a
mess of overlapping on-ramps confused
the hell out of me
all the time Batman uses these two evil
knievel over the cops with the Batpod
but then Batman ditches a bat pod for
the bat and notice how when it first
emerges from the shadows of the alley
behind the spotlight there appear to be
two glowing eyes it looked very similar
to the ones of Batman's cowl the bats
glides over these cops giving us a look
at its structure the production
designers wanted the bat to match the
militaristic look of a tumbler and the
Batpod since they all would have been
two constructed from the same source so
the designers sampled the real-life
Harrier Jump Jet in the Bell Boeing v-22
osprey and the boeing ah-64 Apache then
Batman teams up with Selina in this
rooftop fight and check out Batman's hit
on this guy - yeah check Cala D and
deception after dropping off Selina we
get this gag
this is another detail pulled from the
kingdom come graphic novel when Superman
does this to Bruce and I'll never know
why Bruce is still using his Batman
voice when he's alone
Batman's dangerous heroics lead to this
heartbreaking falling-out with Alfred
special in Alfred reveals that he burned
Rachael's breakup letter in the dark
night without Alfred Bruce is now at his
most vulnerable you might even say that
for Bruce worse than ever and it's
fitting that right after losing his most
trusted protector
Bruce immediately makes a costly mistake
revealing itália al Ghul the location of
the nuclear fusion device allowing her
and Bane to later weaponize it
then at the Wayne board meeting we get
two cameos on the left is John Nolan the
British actor reprising his role from
Batman Begins he's Chris and Jonah
Nolan's uncle and on the left is senator
patrick leahy again he loves Batman he
gets to make cameos and lots of Batman
stuff he was in the Dark Knight as well
and after losing control the company to
Miranda Tate Daggett complaints to Bane
and he does that hand thing and reveals
his agenda to be different than what we
expected and we learned later what that
plan is but no time for that jerks
Bruce hooks up with Miranda and as she
vaguely describes her meager
upbringing he runs his fingers over this
scar on her back this is the same shape
of the scar that was on Bane's head that
I pointed out earlier this is the brand
given to initiates of the League of
Shadows remember we saw Ken Watanabe
--zz character ready to poke Bruce with
that and Batman Begins before Bruce
pieced out now since Bruce doesn't have
that scar himself he doesn't immediately
recognize her connection to the League
of Shadows the block Ian is just really
well done here the scar is only visible
because Miranda slash Talia is leaning
forward to stoke the coals allowing the
blanket to slip down and then after
Bruce touches it she discreetly turns
her back away from him
smooth Selina leads Batman to Bane
through the underground tunnels and
noticed the way Batman takes down all
the guards
you may recognize this same move from
Batman Begins this whole March is kind
of directed like a highlight reel for
Batman it's designed to give us this
false sense of confidence so that it
hurts so much more to see Batman fail
against Bane and you can really feel the
weight of the fight between these two
heavyweights Nolan actually uses a few
cinematic tricks to make Bane appear
even more physically imposing the Batman
notice how he shoots Bane from an upward
pointed angle as the Batman is down
below him looking up at him also if you
listen closely you can hear that the
sound designers amplified Bane's
footsteps so that he makes heavy thuds
whereas Batman's footsteps are quieter
usually Batman's advantage is the
stealth techniques he learned from the
League of Shadows
but since Bane had the same training
that advantage is gone the object on
deception to the uninitiated
beam is echoing Ra's al Ghul's old
techniques to mock Batman for assuming
he's unique theatricality and deception
of powerful agents Bane declares that he
has returned to fulfill Ra's al Ghul's
destiny which is a plot point inspired
from the legacy storyline the comics in
which pain becomes Raza successor and
plots with the League of Shadows to
destroy Gotham Batman tries to cut the
lights but Bane's response here is
interesting the dog loses your honor you
merely adopted the dark I was born in it
molded by it I didn't see the night
until I was already a man by then it was
nothing to me writing to those paying
attention here Bane just revealed that
he couldn't have been the child from the
pit legend if he didn't see the daylight
until he was a man the child who escaped
must have been someone else also notice
how no one circles the camera round Bane
using the same whirlwind camera movement
that he used to convey the Joker's
tornado like force on the hero in the
Dark Knight Selina promise Bruce that a
storm was coming and now Batman is in
the middle of it leading us to the snap
heard around the world
being lifting Batman and breaking his
spine on his knee was straight out of a
night fall comic it's really one of the
most memorable images in Batman history
and Bane walks away droppy and Batman
shattered cowl this rig calls the image
early in Batman Begins when Bruce was
still able to crack early models of his
cowl essentially Bane is reverting Bruce
back to that early powerless pre Batman
state Bane takes Batman to the same
prison he did time in I'm guessing
somewhere in Morocco since the prisoners
rights chant is in Moroccan and here
Bane reveals his true agenda as I tell
my boss and I will heed its people help
to poison their souls and then when it
is done and Gotham is ashes then you
have my permission to die so despite the
Dark Knight Rises political backdrop of
economic inequality Bane explains that
the politics is just a distraction a red
herring ultimately Bane isn't an
ideologue he's just a terrorist using
politics to destabilize society before
he fries it and that is even more messed
up than Ra's al Ghul's plan say what you
will about Roz but at least he didn't
intend on gradually wearing down
Gotham's hope over a five-month
occupation period that's just cruel guys
and as Bruce tries and fails to escape
Bane begins his takeover of Gotham with
this very cool sequence at the football
game now this was all shot at Heinz
Field in Pittsburgh that's where the
Steelers play that explains why Gotham's
colors are black and yellow black and
yellow black nail and many of the
Steelers players actually make cameos
here as players on the Gotham City
rogues you can actually see their names
appearing on the backs of their jerseys
there's Hines Ward and Ben
Roethlisberger Troy Polamalu Willie :
marques Pouncy Mike Wallace Heath Miller
Aaron Smith Ryan Clark James Farrior
Lamar Woodley and Casey Hampton former
Steelers coach Bill Cowher cameos as a
Rogues coach meanwhile the punter for
Rapid City is a cameo by Pittsburgh's
then mayor Luke Ravenstahl he was a
kicker on its college football team the
crowd in the stands are real residents
of Pittsburgh they were told to wear
black in yellow and that they could
bring their own sign so long as they
didn't have profanity on him and
closely you could see this one dudes are
for rogues is the same design as the
Robin are on Tim Drake suits he had no
way of knowing Robin would be in this
movie but it just worked as and that's
coincident Bane's demolition of this
field is pretty frightening just look
how sad Hines Ward looks he's like I
gotta work on my awareness and nolan
combines this spectacle with the wide
shots of demolitions around the city by
mixing in aerial shots of real-life
manhattan nolan once again reflects the
9/11 imagery that provided the
fear-based thematic underpinnings for
his batman series he includes this shot
of downtown Manhattan with digitally
constructed bridges to New Jersey he
added three more though I don't know why
he'd want more bridges to New Jersey and
prominently in the center of the shot is
Freedom Tower it was still under
construction when the movie was being
shot the collapsing bridges definitely
trigger the memory of the collapsing
towers that this tower memorializes also
fun detail here if you look closely you
can see the triple tiered Gotham train
line which was also digitally inserted
in the city Bane snaps the neck of dr.
Powell assuring Gotham that there's no
chance that this bomb can be defused
and he declares that an anonymous
ordinary citizen of Gotham holds the
triggers someone he identifies as a hero
this is another parallelism between Bane
and Batman earlier Batman explained how
the concept of Batman relies on the idea
that Batman could be any face in the
crowd Batman
that was the point bein flips this idea
on its head instead of any face in the
crowd could be a hero now any face in
the crowd could be a mass-murderer and
then Bain gives this big speech outside
Blackgate prison now this whole section
of the movie parallels the French
Revolution Blackgate is based on the
Bastille it was a fortress in Paris
where political dissidents were
imprisoned
it was raided by protesters on July 14
1789 and that is why the French
celebrate Bastille Day Bane is evoking
historical revolutionaries like
maximilien robespierre whom many
historians credit with the most violent
excesses the kangaroo courts and the
public executions of the reign of terror
in the French Revolution period and real
political scientists have actually
analyzed vanes actions in this movie
comparing in to Che Guevara in Cuba and
notice the design of Bane's coat it's a
mix of French Revolution frock coat and
a Swedish army jacket it's intended to
make Bane look equally like a dictator
and a revolutionary and after revealing
Gordon's noble lie Bane tears this photo
of Harvey Dent and notice how he rips it
right down the center of dents face it's
transforming this false image of
Harvey's legacy as this inspirational
hero to the man torn in half that he
secretly became Gotham's transformation
into a war zone was inspired by the no
man's land storyline in the comics in
which Gotham City becomes an apocalyptic
gangland territory cut off from the rest
of the United States back in the pit
Bruce learns more about the legend of
the child of Ra's al Ghul and then speak
of the devil he visits him as a ghostly
hallucination as Bruce's backbone heals
my tone - I was important
ra's referencing immortality in this pit
could be a nod to the Lazarus Pit from
the DC Comics the source of Raz's power
was his routine rejuvenation in these
pits which restores energy now Roz says
there are many forms of immortality
suggesting that this pit is a Lazarus
Pit in a different way providing those
who escaped it with a spiritual
resurrection while Bruce recovers Gotham
remains under occupation and a small
police resistance meet with a special
forces unit notice the symbol that Blake
uses to track the truck routes of course
Blake got this from the orphan kid that
he talked to earlier I liked how this
symbol is simple quick to draw and easy
to miss it contains a hidden V as if to
suggest a victory
kind of like how the V for Vendetta
graphic novel and movie in
anarchy a symbol throughout him in
history various oppressed groups have
drawn similar graffiti symbols with
hidden meanings like when early
Christians were persecuted in Rome they
would draw this this fish symbol to
determine if they could trust each other
also in world war two allied soldiers
would sketch the Kilroy Was Here image
on walls and surfaces to track their
progress and kill where I kind of became
an inside reference among troops kind of
like this symbol is for the gotham
resistance box tells the Special Forces
guys that the bomb will detonate in 23
days which gives us a sense of this
movies timeline earlier when the bomb
was built Bane said that the core would
destabilize in five months
so while Nolan implies the passage of
time by blanketing got them in snow we
can actually estimate that the city has
been under occupation and Bruce has been
in prison recovering for a little over
four months Bane catches the Special
Forces and publicly execute them again
evoking those radical French
revolutionaries in their use of the
guillotine
Bruce reacts to this with another failed
escape attempt resulting in this
interesting flashback so Nolan is
linking this circular imagery of Bruce
looking upward at the prison to one of
the very first shots we saw in Batman
Begins in the well it looks almost
identical this connection is
thematically connecting Bruce's
formative moment as a child with his
redemption as a man
Bruce once realized that he needed the
fear from that trauma falling in the
well and being attacked by bats that
fear became the source of his strength
this movie is suggesting that pain works
the same way
Bruce needed to be broken and buried at
literal rock-bottom so that he can learn
how to live with and fight through
devastating pain something every hero
and every person must do at some point
in our lives so in Bruce's case he
returns himself to that state of fear by
refusing the safety rope something very
stupid and the universe gives him one
last little scare right before the big
jump
as we saw in Batman Begins being swarmed
with bats kind of works as a
psychological supercharged for Bruce and
here it's just enough of a push back in
Gotham we see Bane's kangaroo court
sentencing Stryver and the courts
familiar judge with Killian Murphy
returning as dr. crane the Scarecrow
notice how his coat is tattered with
stuffy and coming out of the seams
making him look particularly scarecrow
II remember in Batman Begins we first
saw crane in a courtroom making a
mockery of the legal system so it's
appropriate that in Rises he returns to
where he began we won't check out what
Bane is doing during this now he
presides over this court leaning back
and knitting this is another nod to A
Tale of Two Cities the villainous
character Madame Defarge would observe
executions in knit knitting the names of
the next intended people to be killed in
this way she symbolized the fates of
Greek mythology who wove and cut the
chords of people's lifelines Defarge is
actually driven by revenge for the death
of her family and it kind of makes Talia
al Ghul more of the Madame Defarge of
this story the sentencing options in
this trial are exile or death with exile
meaning a deadly walk over the ice this
visual is a callback to Batman Begins
when Bruce was with the League of
Shadows and Raz punished him in a
similar way
Bruce returns to Gotham reuniting with
Selina and if you're wondering how Bruce
got halfway around the world so quickly
keep in mind we just heard Gordon tell
his men that the bomb has another 18
hours until detonation subtracting that
from Fox's earlier statement of 23 days
that kind of places Bruce's escape
somewhere in this two to three week
window to me that's enough time for a
guide across the globe and return to a
city that he is a proven master of
getting around in undetected so maybe
don't get too hung up on the timeline
stuff in this movie when they're
detained Miranda says this to Bruce it's
necessary the reveal of her true
identity is just minutes away but this
is one last nod to her father who's the
courage to do what is necessary Bruce
and Fox return to the interim Batcave
from The Dark Knight and Bruce's Dark
Knight era Batsuit Rises literally The
Dark Knight Rises director and it means
actually if you remember this old armor
also exposes Bruce to a vulnerability
that he had in the Dark Knight
separation of the plates makes you more
vulnerable to
gunfire and we will see that
vulnerability exposed with a knife very
soon Batman rescues Gordon from the ice
and he gives him a torch to light a new
bat-signal
but this signal is more elemental it's
the form of fire symbolizing the life
that will melt the ice of Gotham's
frozen state it also may remind you of
that poster for the Dark Knight with a
fiery image on the side of a surface
Batman also saves Blake giving him this
advice if you're working alone wear a
mask
it's another moment foreshadowing the
passing of the torch from Batman to
Robin with Blake learning the values
that Bruce had to learn to become the
hero and notice the last words that they
say to each other hey thanks this is the
night of the past times Batman has
refused to thank you at the ends of
Batman Begins and the Dark Knight thank
you moving on to this climactic street
battle notice how it takes place in
daylight which is a change from the
climax is the first two movies which
remember took place at night the dawn
setting represents Batman's resurrection
from despair some political
misinterpretations of this movie have
criticized the choice to have this final
battle take place with the good guys
being the cops beating hook
revolutionaries preaching leftist ideals
but again this movie is not about that
kind of partisan politics if anything
the images of tattered American flags
and the weary unwashed police officers
more closely evokes the first responders
after the 9/11 attacks whatever you
believe there's no denying the heroism
of a first responder crawling through
collapse rubble in the aftermath of a
terrorist attack in a city it's just one
of the reasons why we really feel the
need for these cops to win the day and I
love the music arrangement of the
sequence
Zimmer composed an altered version of
the rise chance making each syllable
more of a staccato to emphasize the cops
rise from the grave in a march to war
Batman joins the fray and like his
earlier brawl with Bane the sound
editing once again tells us the
direction this fight is going listening
each of Batman's blows they added a
little metallic clink to each punch in a
game that Batman is making contact with
the tubes of Bane's mask these clinks
lead to the first moment Batman actually
draws blood kind of like any good boxing
match in a movie this shakes up the
antagonist and leads to the knockout
sure Selina may be the one to actually
finish off Bane later on but for
dramatic purposes this is Bane's defeat
because he's replaced by the movies true
villain in this moment Talia al Ghul
Talia waxes poetic about knives
Tahlia is echoing the Joker in the Dark
Knight who remember had similar reasons
for preferring knives as his weapon of
choice wanna know why I use a knife guns
are too quick you can't save her
although little emotion Selina saves
Batman leading to this race to the bomb
the shots of the bad Clyde in loathe of
the city just looks so vivid the crew
actually used a practical prop craft
that they had to build and then they
rolled it on a wheeled vehicle they
removed the vehicle and post actually if
you look closely you can see that they
included a dummy of Batman in a suit in
the cockpit we see the bomb counting
down from about eleven and a half
minutes and like with the timer on the
tablet earlier Nolen once again stays
pretty faithful to his own countdown the
various times it cuts back to the timer
throughout the sequence don't always
line up with the movie timecode but when
the bomb eventually goes off over the
water it's about eleven minutes later in
real time that way normally kind of
avoids the stretching or bending of time
that action movies tend to do with the
ticking clock
Batman's end or so we think recalls
another formative moment from Batman
Begins the deaths of his parents he
reveals his identity to Gordon by
reminding him about how Gordon once
consoled him and listen to the music
that plays as Bruce soars out over the
ocean
[Music]
this is that same choirboy solo that
played when Bruce knelt over his slain
parents now we hear it over Blake
because this is a parallel formative
moment for this upcoming hero the moment
that he sees his parental figure die a
montage shows us the city recovery and
as we hear a voice over by Commissioner
Gordon which is a far far better thing
that I do than I have ever done that is
a far far better rest did I go to
[Music]
this is a direct quote of the closing
words from A Tale of Two Cities so I
didn't just make up the connection it's
the final speech by Sydney Carton right
before he sacrifices his life to save
innocent people from slaughter Dickens
repetition of the phrase it is a far far
better in the final line is meant to
mirror the repetition in the opening
line it was the best of times it was the
worst of times
the duality between the two cities in
the book's title similarly this movies
ending mirrors its opening it began with
Gordon eulogizing the white knight now
he eulogizes the Dark Knight and like
Harvey Dent's death
Batman's departure is a noble lie as
well Gotham is better off believing
Batman gave up his life to save them
that way they can be truly inspired to
everyday heroism and Batman can be both
the hero Gotham deserves and the hero it
needs right now and by the way to those
of you who look at this overhead shot of
Batman statue unveiled and see us maile
face or a joker face oh well I just have
one thing to say to that be among the
closing shots is Gordon back on the
rooftop finding that the bat signal has
been repaired reflecting also the
shattered image of the bat signal in the
opening shot representing Bruce's
journey in this movie he started broken
and in pain and now he ends not dead
he's totally alive in that Florence cafe
of Alfred's fantasies boxes team
actually discovered that Bruce fixed the
bats autopilot suggesting that Batman
could have ejected from it before the
bomb exploded that doesn't totally
explain how he swam back to the shore
though maybe he had backup Bruce is
sitting with Selina Kyle and if you look
closely you can see that she's wearing
that pearl necklace that was missing
from Bruce's belongings this suggest
that Bruce has finally truly let go of
his pain the burden of protecting Gotham
and avenging his parents is now behind
him and Selena's his mama
why does Bruce end up with Selina does
this mean that deep down he agrees with
her leftist views his Batman a commie
again this isn't about politics Selina
showed Bruce a heroic selflessness by
returning in to help liberate the city
she saved his life and yeah she's one of
the few people can empathize with the
weirdness of breaking the law and
dressing up as an act animal that's a
keeper but the big reveal in this
closing sequence is John Blake's real
name and notice how the camera cuts to
the reverse shot and her voice changes a
little you should use your full name
I like that name Robin I like that name
Robin it may sound a little different
because Nolan actually recorded the
audio of Robin separately in a private
sound booth he wanted to preserve the
secret of this final reveal for most of
the cast and crew of the film the final
images show Blake looking particularly
Robin II acrobatically swinging into the
Batcave not unlike a flying Grayson
presumably Blake would go on to be the
Dick Grayson Nightwing version of the
character since he would now be the main
hero and not a sidekick to Batman he
holds up the torch and gets swarmed by
bats exactly like Bruce's iconic
exposure moment from Batman Begins the
moment he showed that he conquered his
fear became one with it so essentially
these final few minutes have
fast-tracked Blake's hero's journey
reflect in Batman's story beats a tragic
loss of a mentor shedding of the old
identity and embracing fear as an
inspiration and the final image
completes this journey for the hero who
rises up out of frame lifted by the
darkness but using that darkness to
enter the light and here's a question I
kind of want to know from you guys
wouldn't you watch a Joseph
gordon-levitt Nightwing movie I kind of
want to know how this hasn't happened
yet and a broader question after
watching all these movies since the Dark
Knight is really the undisputed best of
the trilogy after reviewing them all
which movie holds up as better Batman
Begins or the Dark Knight Rises I've
always seen Batman Begins as simpler and
more elegant in a lot of ways and it
kind of felt like a breath of fresh air
when it came out caught us by surprise
in the best possible way but now part of
me feels like if the Dark Knight didn't
exist and no one just followed up Atman
begins with Rises as the immediate
sequel there would be no question that
the Dark Knight Rises was a huge step up
everyone would be heaping praise on this
movie sure sure sure not all of the
movies ambitious elements come together
as neatly as they did with the Dark
Knight but damn you've got to admit this
is one hell of a movie comment down
below with your thoughts and like this
video share it around and make sure to
watch my breakdowns of Batman Begins in
the Dark Knight if you haven't already
it is pin a delight to watching this
movies with you and we'd love to do this
with more classic movies so subscribe to
new rockstars for similar in depth
breakdowns of all the stuff that you
love and please please spread the word
about this so that we can make sure the
far are gee I don't know if I helped
fight